now is it true that you know well it is
true you almost broke the internet
because there was I took my shirt off
yeah exactly and revealed that gorgeous
long torso that you do your underpants
with your wife too
um so this guy is watching the office on
a plane
um he had no clue who you were yeah I so
the the coven mask is is such a boon for
traveling when you're a recognizable
actor so I wear mine everywhere and uh
here I am on a plane from Boston to L.A
it's a five hour plane ride the entire
five hours and 27 minutes the guy's
watching the office episodes right next
to me I've got my mask on right there
and then uh it was it was great because
people want to know the resolution of
the story so I posted about it and
people were freaking out and as we were
Landing I kind of nudged them I'm like
you seem to like that show huh and he's
like oh yeah it's my favorite show and I
was like yeah I heard it wasn't so good
tell me about it and then I was slowly
slowly taking my mask off I was like oh
this is gonna be delicious and he was
like yeah I um well it starts slow you
know the first season's kind of weak and
you kind of got to get to know the
characters a little bit but if you stick
with it but I like oh the first season's
kind of slow huh it's not so good it
gets better later on huh and he's like
yeah well you know and then he was like
foreign
and he he couldn't believe it um it was
it was a really beautiful magical
experience
I feel when you're
a part of something that someone sits
and absorbs for five and a half hours
next to you knowing that they're most
likely eating this delicious meal and
it's fulfilling that well it's been such
a roller coaster ride you know we were
almost canceled so many times when we
first started and then we were a big hit
and then we slowly slowly dwindled in
the last several seasons not many people
were watching us and then it went went
away and then like you know 2015 16 17
no one was thinking or talking about the
office and then all of a sudden the
Advent of streaming and uh and now it's
on peacock and uh and then covid it's
it's it's insane you you're so lucky to
be on any TV show and then one that
lasts you're double lucky and then one
that is loved
um you know I'm really the luckiest man
alive we all are to have been a part of
that uh which is now a phenomenon it
really really is there are games about
it people are the character
um is it true that before you were wait
you lived in an abandoned beer factory
yeah what's what's so weird about that
no when I was a broke actor starting out
in New York I didn't have any money I
was out of acting school there was this
weird we ran into this weird Dutch
landlord and he's like I've got this
abandoned beer brewery and you can move
in and we're going to fix it into
artists Lofts and we're like oh lovely
that sounds fun artist lofts it was just
some kind of tax scam he just wanted
some people that were artists living
there so he could like write the whole
thing off we didn't have heat we didn't
have running water the front door was a
loading dock door for like the beer
truck so I'd have to climb up the wall
and like
and go up and and that was my front door
and then this was out in a really bad
neighborhood of Brooklyn and uh local
kids thought it was hysterical to
occasionally throw like bottles and
rocks at us as we were climbing into our
house where we lived was there toilets
there was a toilet down a floor but you
had to navigate the rats to get there
yeah but it was free and I took my my
tips as a waiter and I stuffed them into
this pocket and I had a big wad of cash
and then I was able to move out
eventually
so happy for her like journey and
trajectory Look At Me Now America I know
you have this new project yeah where you
know you the geography of bliss that's
right what is the geography of bliss and
what are the coordinates
where is bliss well here we have a scene
of me trying to find Bliss in Bulgaria
um I got to travel the world and instead
of sampling food I got to search for
happiness
so we went to Iceland we went to
Thailand
Bulgaria Ghana and even back home in Los
Angeles you know asking the question
like how and how do we find well-being
and are there clues that we can glean
from other cultures to enrich our own
lives what did you find out there I'll
tell you what I found and it really is
pretty simple it's pretty common sense
and that is it's all about connection
it's all about the groups that you have
it's about family it's about larger
Community it's about Grassroots it's
people coming together to be out in
nature it's people coming together to
sing and make art it's people coming
together to do service to others it's
all us human beings as we've learned
during covid we need to stay connected
and it doesn't matter where you go
Iceland or Thailand that's where real
Joy is found
thank you truly thank you so much rain
Wilson the geography of bliss premieres
May 18th streaming exclusively on
peacock
[Music]